[Music]
you don't want to put women down so why
do you think that they may have been
impressed I have an impression because
there's a lot of videos that are you
know issues that involve women and
that's because that's what we deal with
deal with women there's a lot of things
in this equality era that's fight for
equality we do we deal with right now in
this era there's a lot of things that
are emitted and we don't talk about it
it's like those problems or non-existent
or not they're not soft abouts we
recognize that there's inequalities
between men and women but there's a lot
of we don't talk about we want equality
but the fight for equality is
discrediting the issues that women have
I'm not doing that at all that is not
the point you're able and you have the
right to talk about your issues cool
same way white people share this right
to talk about the issues as well sorry
misogynistic women are toxic that's not
bad we're just weird to say okay if you
want equality we're gonna talk about the
toxicity of everybody people can be
toxic let's not paint a picture where
women are right and men are wrong that's
not even the case the toxicity of these
ladies he says it exists as well both
games it's hard to hear that sometimes
like again again again there are people
talking about your problems I believe
that feminism is seen you don't have to
help men and that's fine
[Music]
she's a futurist and you show that
you're able to you can set your toxic
masculinity
give me a reason right there right now
right now there's a lot of toxicity just
growing out of your ports it's caught it
is bothering if called facial hair your
face okay
yeah you screwed a woman's face and said
oh my girls like she's been told she has
to like that because picture dresses
doesn't wanna wear skirts doesn't want
to use Gillette razors probably doesn't
like brie Larson listen he's got all
kinds of problems yes but how are you
gonna you can't lay with the magnets and
fly like a butterfly
pick one choose one you are the one
who's disappointed okay so she gets the
most flack but I probably get the most
angry preacher didn't he's no sixteen so
I've had to be in two ladies and over
the years
I've just seen a lot of behavior and
it's mid behavior that I've known to be
detrimental I mean I love my mom but
growing up most of my life my mom had
this terrible habit of nagging you to
the point where you were going crazy and
we don't talk about that form of
toxicity and I never understood it how
negative impacted because me today
I still live for that like if a woman
nags me once I totally leave Michael I
get out I can't like if you tell me I'm
good enough to trash another quad take
it out in a minute
and if 20 seconds later you say it again
I'll tell you to leave right away I
can't I can't but that's just how rates
not affected me for a long time and over
the course of dating experiences I would
see women be you know physically if I
would see with me and say things that I
thought were unacceptable just a lot of
behavior that I'm I raised you but I
can't be mad at them because of the fact
that none of this is spoken about in
mainstream media nobody talks about all
of the stuff you know I mean we talk
about we would be like yeah be a man
women always say that you know like
people mostly vulnerable cool and then
they use your vulnerability against you
nobody talks about that nobody talks
about the fact that women feel
comfortable stopping you and hitting you
even when they're just like right you
can put your hands on well then nobody
told it was unacceptable a lot of people
I'm dated I hate when I hear this - I
just dated crazy no I didn't these are
good photo shooting people that I've
dated but they live in a society where
they've never been taught that that kind
of behavior is unacceptable
ever and so I'm dealing with this
negative stuff I'm being told how to
behave for me and she was deciding how
to be a better person because my
behaviors wrong and I'm like okay so I
just and I'm learning and I'm trying to
do better but nobody's telling you so
just she taught me women I've told you
like hey do you go this is Rob living
with Tommy and I have to walk them
through it explain the logic you know
that Bob look wait nobody ever told you
no it's unacceptable cuz to use people's
emotional vulnerability against them
really no nobody told you that it's kind
of a double standard that you expect men
to lead and to be stoic when it matters
but also you expect them to be
emotionally vulnerable although
something knows what that does make
sense
nobody tense
that you expect men to pay for
everything when it goes to dinner and
fun times but you don't want to pay me
that even though you claim to be an
intersectional womanist oh they just
don't know something want to know
something don't care they want to keep
things away but some of them also don't
know and I think when I start to speak
on these topics I find myself swelling
up because I'm reliving certain
experiences or I'm drawing from that's
happened to write stuff that I know is
thinking something know was unjust and
I've had to tolerate because of a man
and she's a woman and when you live in a
society that encourages that sometimes
it'll get you a little riled up and so
when I'm making these videos I catch
myself of my problem what am I in you
understand now so I'm trying to do a
better job of not letting those emotions
flare up when I talk about this stuff
but it's difficult it's difficult
because I can assure you most of the
negative stuff that's happened to me in
my life has been as a result of it and
that's something that no one you may not
want to please but it's the truth
and not bad people not my intention
people just people who didn't know so if
you want some are not bad they do bad
things because they don't know their VAD
and so unless we talk about it how we're
going to move forward and the reason why
men gravitates so much towards your
content is because of the fact that
nobody says that there's a void we're
filling there's a gap so it's not that
we're the best voices for this it's not
that we have the most intelligent
discussions or all that stuff is the
fact that nobody's talking about in the
mainstream nobody's allowed to and so
finally people are feeling how do you
think the Joe Rogan podcast got so big
part because he's a great entrepreneur
part because he's a great interview but
also because you've never had a male
Oprah all this to say what you guys see
is massaging him I know this has just
been a long time of men having to be
silent about a lot of stuff that you
ladies do because of the fact that
society says it's okay for y'all doing
pretty much so that's wrong the topics
come from that's where these discussions
come from and that's why we're trying to
provide an insight whenever I ask
someone why you think work misogynist
they're like well look at your comments
that's not me that's not us no and yes
they're people that go overboard in the
comments they are but don't make it that
is me it's not me doing that is you to
the Internet if that's the only argument
you don't have one you know what tubes
go sewers you know what's in the sewer
starfish
[Music]
not just that one a lot of people think
you need back with it because I girl we
do these videos because it serves you
this we do it because we enjoy it but
also because it's useful to a lot of
people it is you know what people can
look at their own behavior and fix a lot
of stuff that they're going through my
grief I'm happy to hear that people are
trying to be better people that were
popular that did serve any purpose
because when we have a subject some
people want us to talk about a subject
but if we have a stance that is not
adding to the conversation or another
side of the story
we don't do it interesting to me to see
another question that question
everything but you've seen on panels
where we'll spin us and seven other PCs
are the people speak first they say
pretty much everything that's the attain
you want me to repeat and I'd like when
this might become I've nothing to say
cuz you've already covered it I don't
know I'm not just talking into a point
to talk into a void you know just like
to make some cash it's not interested to
me so I serve people then I would stop
doing this I find fulfillment in this
work or you could serve Jesus true
what's true alternative back-up plan
Jesus baby Jesus but when I was in
Portugal like a couple of person he said
you know I love your videos I appreciate
what you guys doing thank you he's like
by the way like I show my views to my
girlfriend and we talk about them and it
helps us in a relationship and I'm like
don't that to me is like one of the best
there's like within each other they're
learning to better communicate and
better understand each other so that's
all you
one of these things so hopefully you
guys better understand why we cover some
of the topics that we do it's not a
thing on one minute just that's what we
do it and there's a lot of problems that
are not covered